alors c'est aux câlins chemin va être
remplacé non ne dévoile à nous parler du
burger quiz kelly voilà qu'elle aime
beaucoup c'est l'émission qu'elle
regarde tous les mercredis et donc est
donc alors alain chabat va être remplacé
ce que vous pensez que ça va s'effondrer
sans alain chabat levé avant la baja
mais je pense que sarah s'effondre à un
petit peu de 200 voire 300 mille
téléspectateurs avec avec commandeur et
d'armes au mais ça reviendra quand alain
chabat reviendra parce qu'il est supposé
revenir en bateau moi j'adore jérôme
commandeur en plus c'est vrai mais les
rangs de ses six prêtres que c'était une
très bonne idée de faire venir très
bonne et de faire que 40
wen revanche je pense qu'à la fin des 40
il fallait faire une pause un break
et puis ensuite revenir là on commence à
se lasser un tout petit peu l'émission
et puis se lasser et en plus ne plus
voir chabat pense que mathématiquement
ça va chuter il a tout dit il a tout dit
merci c'est moi où nous fêtons rien
[Rires]
pourquoi tf1 m'a dit ils remettent pas
un animateur parce qu'ils savent très
bien que ça va s'effondrer tout
doucement donc le seul moyen de
stabiliser cette créé la curiosité à
chaque fois ils vont mettre des mecs
tournée et moi je vais me faire avoir à
chaque fois dire ah bah tiens je regarde
ralliant soir c'est lui voilà c'est fait
c'est lui et c'est comme ça qu'ils vont
stabiliser mais j comme jeter comme
christine ça va mais c'est peut-être là
bas c'est une bonne idée alors de la
part de tf1
bah ils ont passé pas moins leur demande
pas dit pourra jouer à l'épaule il va le
faire une émission ou d'un courage aux
gens seraient pas super on prend des
tons l'audience me décourage jamais car
elle part en tournage oui le remplacer
wahiba il va il va revenir mais pas tout
de suite oui moi j'aime passionnément
gérard darmon mais je suis pas sûr que
son débit et 100 soit bonne pour le
moral est excellent je vous dis pas
récupéré moi je pense que c'était le
meilleur choix
chabat meilleures conditions qu'est ce
qu'on fait
[Musique]
dites la vérité vous êtes tu es libre ce
soir enfin burger quiz c'est de la merde
maintenant fait l'émission du siècle
passé
géraldine maillet vous la reine des
bobos alors là vous êtes un gros demi
n'a pas fait ça chez vous nous emmerdez
paillard est monté c'est de la vieille
animations c'est mignon assez
franchement j'aimerais demander et
j'aimerais demander bas la plus jeune
d'entre nous mais non il y en a deux
c'est qu'il y est
delphine telle finesse que tu es ce que
tu aimes bien tous ces vieux oui oui non
il avait arrêté
j'aime bien j'aime bien l'humour de
beurre urcuit je trouve juste que une
émission qui est personnifié comme ça on
peut pas changer
non mais ce que peut-être de l'émission
oui ouais elle est particulière je
passais les diverses
non ça scintille particulier et ils
l'assument c'est ce que voulait dire
c'est que la curiosité au fur et à
mesure des semaines quand une émission
n'est pas tenue avec un chef avec une
personnification
tu nous dis pas qu'il ya vérité ja
vérité web un centime oui comme tu
donnes souvent la tienne
mais selon toi oui moi je regarde pas du
tout c'est pas du tout une émission je
me sens pas concerné ni les questions
liées mais surtout pas l'humour
d'ailleurs et ni le rythme de l'émission
que je trouve trop lent non mais c'est
hyper fin commun mais n'en veut pas
kelly kelly est très fine non mais il
est très intelligent tendance n'est pas
de bêtises non mais c'est rigolo mais je
rigole mais elle a le droit de donner
son avis comme vous vous si vous vous
aimez vous émettez canada king bébé
voilà et moi je suis moi presque jamais
dit moi je suis pas comme un ouf non
plus mais ça va aller mieux mais c'est
vrai que je suis moi je regarde le match
je regarde que des émissions de crime
quand il y aura des cris d'horreur cus